there's an expression we use for an
unlikely or impossible event
when something is little or no chance we
say that it has a snowball's chance in
hell but those are the kinds of odds we
like in our experiment through going to
send the snowball to hell and try to
bring it back safely
we'll be attempting this at an old
foundry where the molten metal reaches
temperatures of over 2,000 degrees we
think this makes it pretty much the
closest thing to hell that exists on
earth to pull this off we got GE
scientists and engineers at the global
research center to collaborate and come
up with a solution they drew on
technology from the power aviation and
healthcare industries and developed a
vessel made from a special super alloy
it was engineered to withstand
incredibly high temperatures so we
normally use it to build jet engines
which have to endure extreme
environmental stresses but it was never
designed for this we're putting the
snowball in a specially designed 3d
printed holder and then placing that in
our vessel
then we lower it into a vat and
completely cover it in molten metal slag
and when we pull it out we hope our
snowball will be intact
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]